>> Well, as far as as what's being done for
the Middle East, right now
it seems like such a stalemate.
It seems like there are two steps back for
every step forward.
And right now, I don't feel a lot of optimism
that there's going be to
progress, certainly not through the conventional
methods.
That is to say, through the political pathways
that have been
entrenched in the negative approach for so
long.
But I do think at a grassroots level, there's
a better understanding of
the need to resolve this so that there is
greater stability.
And I do believe that resolving, especially
the Israeli/Palestinian
situation, will make a big difference to a
lot of other areas around
the world.
The whole Islamophobia and the negativity
that comes out of that, and
the sort of the radicalization of many Muslims
comes founded in that
there seems to be an imbalance or an unfair
approach to the
Israeli/Palestinian situation.
So I think there is hope at a grassroots level
of moving forward.
As far as the politicians, I think we have
a long way to go.